well let's crack on shall we with our
first interview we can hear from the
transport secretary Mark Harper
thank you very much for being on the
program this morning good to have you
here and I just want to start with the
Online safety bill so people who
encourage others to self-harm on the
Internet by social media perhaps now
face criminal prosecution and this of
course comes after the really sad case
of Molly Russell who took her own life
when she was just 14 years old what I'm
confused about is is this just applying
to children or will it cover adults as
well well look people don't have very
much longer to wait the the second day
of debate in the House of Commons on
this important piece of legislation is
going to take place on Monday the 5th of
December in just over a week's time and
as is the proper process ministers will
set out any government amendments
they're asked for the legislation at the
dispatch box in the House of Commons so
you'll just have to be a little bit more
a little bit more patient at the same
time though I mean this has been briefed
out today I'm not just jumping on this
because I want to find out you know you
you guys are putting this out today
there's often speculation in the media
about what is or isn't going to be in
pieces of legislation this isn't
speculation this has been briefed out
well there's often speculation in the
media I think it's better if ministers
set out any plans that there are in the
House of Commons at the dispatch box
then they can set out all of the detail
about what the government proposes and
allow people to take questions on it so
look it's coming to the House of Commons
I know it's an important piece of
legislation it'll actually be
groundbreaking legislation globally
ministers have worked on it and I know
campaigners like Mr Russell have worked
on it for you know campaigned on it for
many years but we're going to have that
date that further day of debate in just
over a week's time um all will become
clear about what the government's plans
are at that point I mean you say it's
groundbreaking and it clearly is you
know lots of parents really worried
about it but not just parents this is
something that affects so many people as
well and so I guess that's why I'm just
trying to find out who it applies to it
feels like quite a big deal to me you
know if it's just children or if it's
everybody well look ministers have taken
a lot of trouble to get this right and
they've been you know there have been
lots of people wanting to make sure we
protect children which is absolutely
right and then there of course been
people who are very concerned about
getting the balance right about free
speech so ministers have taken the
trouble to listen to people's concerns
and to get those right and they'll set
out the decisions that the government's
made in Parliament in just over a week's
time so people don't have long to wait
you're talking there about um people's
concerns over free speech I mean Kevin
up for example of your own uh cabinet
colleague saying over the summer we
should not be legislating for hurt
feelings let's worry about this on the
conservative side right well look
there's been a debate amongst lots of
people about getting the balance right
now legislation there are no on these
sort of difficult subjects there are no
easy answers it's about balancing
different things that you have to be
concerned about protecting children is
very clearly what the government wants
to do and then it's dealing with the
other issues but making sure that you
don't uh clamp down on free speech so
there's a balance to strike there as I
said the government will set out you
know where where we've made decisions uh
in just over a week's time in Parliament
where the legislation comes back for a
further day of debate are you not
telling us whether it's just children or
if it's adults as well because you don't
know or because you just don't think we
should be told yet no I'm telling you
there's a proper process in Parliament
you know as a former Chief whip I happen
to think it's quite important that when
ministers set out policies uh that they
set them up in Parliament first where
members of parliament can hold them to
account on behalf of their constituents
you know there'll be people in
Parliament who are been campaigning on
these issues ministers can set up the
detail because on these subjects the
detail matters they can set out what the
government proposes in detail and then
there's a full debate in Parliament on
Monday the 5th okay now talking about
harmful Behavior there's another story
that I want to talk to you about and
this is the report into misogyny and
racism in the London fire brigade and
I'll be honest you know I've been a
journalist for many years I've been
genuinely quite shocked by some of the
examples that this review uncovered you
know like a Muslim firefighter having
pork sausages put in his pocket a woman
having her helmet filled with urine
who is the man leading the review and
said that he's been contacted by lots of
people from you know the BBC the NHS
police forces he wants to see a national
inquiry now into other public bodies do
you agree with him well look on the
London fire brigade issue specifically I
listened to the examples that were set
out and frankly they were absolutely
appalling you know I I worked in
business before I was in politics and
that behavior just wouldn't be
acceptable in any workplace
um I was heartened to listen to what the
commissioner of the London fire brigade
said which is that he accepted the
report in full accepted there was a big
job of work to do in his organization
and he made it clear that that job
started now and he was clear that he was
going to root out people who behaved in
such a way and I thought that was very
good now when you talk about criminal
charges as well didn't he yes and it was
obviously that that inquiry was
triggered by a specific case I
understand of the tragic suicide of
someone who took their own life as a
result of bullying and that's what
triggered the report I don't know of any
similar examples elsewhere so I think
look the important thing here is I've
listened to what was set out in that
report there's clearly some real issues
in the London fire brigade but the
leadership of the London fire brigade
the commissioner has made it very clear
that he he's going to accept all the
recommendations in full and he's going
to make it his mission to sort out that
organization and that sort of leadership
I think that you want when issues are
identified I guess my question about
wisding it out is because it feels like
you know whenever we start lifting up
Stones whether it's in the London fire
brigade whether it's in the Met police
this kind of thing is uncovered
shouldn't we start a typically turning
up more Stones elsewhere well look I
think one thing that comes through very
clearly from this and that came through
from the commissioner's reply is a lot
of these things are about leadership so
I think what that report highlights
every leader of every organization I
think should read that report and just
think about whether the way they conduct
themselves and the way they lead their
organization means that that sort of
behavior wouldn't be able to happen in
their organization but do you think that
there's actually all leaders I think but
do you think they should be more
inquiries we can't just be happening in
London can it well look that that
inquiry was set up as there was the the
response to a specific set of events I
don't think you want every organization
uh in the entire country where there
hasn't been a specific event to be
setting up inquiries all over the place
but I do think all leaders of
organization should look at that report
and think about whether it could happen
in their organization and if they think
it could then they should think about
what they need to do about making sure
it couldn't okay let's talk transport
shall we are the transport secretary
after all uh the UK is facing more rail
strikes how were your talks this week
with the rmt's mick Lynch well look if I
just said it in context I think the
difference with the rails uh situation
the rail dispute and the strikes that
have Arisen is that there's some this is
a long-running uh dispute far too long
running actually and what this is about
is about modernizing the railways so
there are a lot of practices in the
right ways that we we don't see
elsewhere you know we don't have for
example a railway that runs properly on
seven days it depends on lots of
Goodwill from workers coming in on days
that are what they what are called rest
days so what we're trying to do
is modernize the railway uh make it more
efficient and make it more flexible to
deal with what passengers need that's
the important thing what passengers need
that then frees up savings and those
savings will then be available to help
give workers a pay rise and also free up
some money that can then go back to the
taxpayer which is having to subsidize
the rail industry so that's what the
negotiations between employers and trade
unions are about and what I what I
originally I met Mr Lynch and Mr Ward
from the tssa this week was to just try
and help move that process so my job I
think is to encourage the two sides in
the negotiations to reach a conclusion
it's not my job to do the negotiations
but I'm very happy on behalf of the
public to do what I can to get us to a
resolution of the disputes so how were
the talks then they can't mean that
great because the strike's still going
ahead well look I think it was the first
time I'd met Mr Mr Lynch uh Mr Warden we
had very sensible discussions very
constructive that's what I thought
that's what he thought
um
well because he came out onto the steps
of the department after the meeting and
that's what he said uh so I'll take him
with his his word at face value we had a
very constructive conversation uh and I
want to see the trade unions get back
around the table and I hope we can make
enough progress so that they would feel
able to call off those strikes I know
how damaging they are for passengers
also not just for passengers but of all
those businesses I'm very struck by the
hospitality industry uh how important
Christmas is for the hospitality
industry you know I stood up for the
hospitality industry last Christmas when
there were rumors you know people wanted
to close down the country again the
Prime Minister when he was Chancellor
stood up for the hospitality industry
and we want to protect them which is why
we want to see an end to this dispute
um you mentioned there are obviously
strikes going on elsewhere I know
there's a specific situation I should
say with rail workers but they obviously
want to see a pay rise as well do you
think public sector workers should
expect to see their pay keep up with
inflation well look I can understand why
that's what people want to achieve but I
think we do have to set in context so
we're facing very difficult economic
situation uh there's the getting the
economy back on track after the pandemic
there's the war in Ukraine it's worth
remembering that the economy the amount
we're spending on dealing with higher
energy prices it's the equivalent of a
whole new National Health Service right
so that's the economic contest we had an
awesome statement where we got the
public finances back on track stabilize
the economic situation we're seeing
interest rates now not having to rise as
much as they would otherwise have to do
um that that is the context so I think
we want to make sure people have pay
Rises but they've got to be pay Rises
that are affordable for the public
sector and in the The Wider economic
context so are you effectively saying
then that an inflation matching pay rise
is unaffordable in the public sector yes
I think inflation matching or inflation
busting pay Rises are unaffordable and I
think we want to try and give all the
workers in the public sector who work
very hard decent pay is but they can't
be inflation busting pay Rises it simply
isn't the money to pay for those but at
the same time by the way we haven't seen
those in the private sector either the
private sector pay Rises have generally
been
um settled below the level of inflation
as well which I accept is difficult for
people but there is just some honesty I
think you're going straight with people
about the economic context the country
faces at the same time in the Autumn
statement we did see some inflation
matching increases in people's income so
if you're looking at for example
pensions they're going to rise in line
with inflation benefits too including
out of work benefits you know if it's
good enough for people who are not
working why isn't it good enough for
people who are working well look we we
made a commitment in the manifesto about
the triple lock for pensions which we
you remember we suspended for one year
when there was some anomalies in the
statistics and it was important to put
that back and of course pensioners have
no ability to alter their hours or take
any steps to increase their income and
of course most of the people who are on
benefits people on universal credit for
example you huge proportionism of course
which is why um specifically talk about
and they're working on low wages often
uh and work incredibly hard to put food
on the table and they're of course on
the lowest incomes and it's the other
reason of course why the national living
wage is going up significantly that'll
give her 1600 pound pay rise I think to
those who are on the lowest incomes but
working hard and those are the steps the
government can take but you've got to be
honest with people you're the public
purse won't uh afford inflation busting
pay Rises for everybody in the public
sector okay um just finally on transport
we you know whenever I say that I'm
talking to transport secretary there's
so many people who get in touch with
their horror stories effectively of
using the transport system in the United
Kingdom so I just want to play you one
example of many that we could play Let's
have a listen
yeah I've got to go home and see my son
and I've pre-booked my tickets to get
them cheaper to find out that my train
from here to Doncaster was canceled so I
had to purchase another ticket for 25
pounds and then when I got to the
station this morning at Andover I found
out they've got trained from Andover to
London Waterloo had been canceled so now
I've got a two-hour way between trains
and I've had to I've had to Fork out an
extra 60 pounds
I just want to play this because
everyone's going to have a story like
this you know is our rail system really
fit for purpose look I I completely
sympathize with that woman and her
experience I've had experiences like
that myself part of the point I think
actually all those stories absolutely
back up the case for reform Workforce
reform and modernizing how our Railways
operate I mean at the moment we're far
too dependent on you know expecting
drivers to work on their rest days we
need a proper seven-day Railway that
works efficiently seven days a week that
people can count on for their important
appointments whether it's for family
visits like that lately okay or for
going to work okay now just before we
move on to a little bit uh more detail
on the conservative party just quickly
on manston the Immigration Center we
have had of course reports of someone
very sadly dying from diphtheria has
enough care being taken there well look
we take the care of of people the
welfare of people in our care very
seriously I know the UK Health security
agency has been working very closely
with the NHS and my understanding is the
the numbers of course that Manson have
now been brought back down to the proper
levels on the dip Theory issue there's
extremely low risk to The Wider
Community that's a disease which of
course the vaccination for which is in
the standard childhood vaccination
package so the health security what
about people in these centers you know
there's enough care being taken of them
and their health we take the welfare of
people in our care very seriously my
understanding is those cases were people
who had that disease before they came to
the United Kingdom and of course as I
said the health Security Agency is
working very closely with the NHS to
make sure we look after the people that
have been identified with diphtheria to
make sure that they get the treatment
and care that they need and if they're
identified are they then tracked are we
do we keep tabs on them well the
appropriate steps will be taken by the
health security agents the point of
getting the health Security Agency
involved is to make sure we take the
proper steps both to protect the
individuals but also to make sure that
we look after the wider community
uh now Rishi sunak has been in power for
just a matter of weeks I guess and so
far it's been pretty steady as just as
he goes you know nothing to rock the
markets um one conservative Source
telling the times on Saturday that
boring is the new sexy is it well look I
think what he's about is a government
that's grown up that grips the issues
that people are concerned about gets on
with governing I mean look I accept that
the summer was difficult uh and I think
what we need understatement is get our
heads Down group the issues that people
are concerned about like that lady and
the issue she's got about the rail
service you know that's what I'm doing
as the transport secretary gripping the
issues dealing with them and having a
government that people think is on top
of the issues of the day and getting on
with sorting them out for the public at
home the only issue is there hasn't
really been anything to move the dial
either I just want to have a look at the
latest poll tracker this is the yougov
tracker poll and you know there has been
a bit of a narrowing you can see in the
polls but it's nowhere near the levels
that you need if you are going to have a
chance of winning the next election I
mean it's boring just the new boring
well look I think if we're being
realistic about it you're not going to
you're not going to turn things around
overnight I think to be fair to the
public the public after the events of
the summer want to see a period of
sensible grown-up government and if I
look at how the two party leaders rate
up between Rishi sunak and Kirsten I
think Rishi zunek has very strong uh
ratings on dealing with the economic
miles behind labor that's the party
thing but the the ratings of the Prime
Minister are actually ahead of the
leader of the opposition you know I
think that that means I think people are
prepared to listen to what we've got to
say but not everyone shares your point
of view are they going to be but look
they're going to be people are going to
be skeptical about it and that's fine
including we're gonna have to
demonstrate grown-up competent
government and that's how we'll win
people back
um ahead of the next elections own party
as well though isn't that you know s
McVay saying the Autumn statement was
the final nail in the conservative
election chances so John Redwood I can't
believe the Prime Minister will want to
fight an election with Promises of tax
wise as an austerity to come that won't
rule the voters back and just to read
out a list of the concept of MPS who
said they're going to stand down at the
next election William ragg Chloe Smith
Gary Street and Nigel Adams Charles
Walker Chrisman blunt Adam Freya to
Hannah Davidson it's not exactly a
glowing vote of confidence from your own
side well look I'll take a couple of
things on the colleagues that are
standing down the reason why those are
coming out all in one go now it's quite
normal that as you get towards an
election various people for their own
reasons decide they're not going to
stand again but there's a specific
deadline in place because of the
boundary changes the parties asked
colleagues to say whether they're going
to stand and set that out before the 5th
of December so you know you're going to
see those all Bunch together so I don't
think there's anything particular to
write home about that on the fact that
we Face very difficult decisions I mean
look the Autumn statement was difficult
I think you know the chancellor said a
number of times that he was having to
take difficult decisions the point of
that is to level with the country about
the challenge we face you know these are
Global challenges the third of the world
is going to be facing recession uh you
know two-thirds of the the developed
countries have inflation above seven
percent facing exactly the same
challenges that we do what the country
wants to know is that they've got a
government and a prime minister that
grips those challenges takes the
decisions that are necessary to get us
on a path for long-term growth and
that's what we saw in the Autumn
statement last a couple of weeks ago now
you're a former Chief whip as you
mentioned earlier in the interview at
Matt Hancock how the conservative whip
suspended when he entered the jungle for
I'm a celebrity but he's now made the
final and so if the public forgave him
do you think the conservative party
should should he have the whip restored
well look one thing is the former Chief
whip is that I'm not going to tell the
current chief whip how to do his job and
look I still hold the position that I
held when I was first asked about Mr
Hancock
um at the beginning if you're a member
of Parliament and Parliament is sitting
I think your job is to be representing
your constituents either in your
constituency or in Parliament I don't
think serving members of parliament
should be taking place in reality
television programs you know however
well they do on them I still think they
should be doing the job for which they
are paid a good salary which is
representing their constituents and you
know that's the position I held but look
The public's going to make a decision
about how that program shapes up I mean
I have to confess I haven't been
watching it so I'm not quite fully up to
speed with what's been going on at the
same time though shouldn't you believe
in second chances I mean you know you
resigned from cabinet yourself didn't
you after you was found that your
cleaner didn't have permission to work
in the UK you're now back in the cabinet
shouldn't Matt Hancock have a second I
think the cheat that's the decision for
the chief Whip and one of the things I
respected when I was Chief whip was that
former Chief whips didn't tell me how to
do my job so I'm going to let the chief
whip make those decisions I think and I
think he'll be grateful that I'm not
interfering understood thank you very
much tough time of it they managed to
get through
uh Mark Harper their transport secretary
um saying that actually in his view
inflation matching or inflation busting
pay rises in the public sector are
unaffordable well it's our chance now to
talk to our Deputy political editor at
Sam coats just to try and find out what
really stood out to him from our main
political interview this morning uh Sam
what did you make of Mark Harper
good morning Sophie well Mark Harper
talked about Second Chances really the
question is whether or not the public
are going to end up giving the
conservatives a second chance what
really struck me wasn't one particular
newsline out of your interview though
there were many it was the tone and Mark
Harper liked the wider Rishi sunak
government is just adopting a much
calmer perhaps understandably tone when
dealing with problems but it's a lot
more managerial it's a lot less Punchy
it's a lot less fighty it's a lot less
um it's not designed to get the kind of
uh the heart pumping and the blood
flowing essentially what they're saying
is we know there are big problems now
give us some time to sort that out and
that's whether that's uh letting the
fire brigade sort themselves out it's
whether it's sorting out the
long-running strikes dispute it's
whether it's a sort of calmer attempt to
deal with public sector pay they think a
new tone will ultimately go down well
with the public but there isn't much
outside of the public buying it yet when
it comes to the wider conservative party
indeed in part this week there's just
been that smell of death with the number
of Tory MPS standing down Mark Harper
rightly says part of that is because of
a deadline but you've got to look like
you've got to look at questions why
young conservative MPS with a strong
trajectory in a large majority are
standing down if they want uh if they
see the conservative party as a party
with a future I think Richie sunax team
needs to make politics a bit more
exciting or otherwise kierstama
previously derided as perhaps the uh
more beige member of the of the fight to
be in number 10 next time could actually
end up getting an edge